tanjiro as the embodiment of kindness
even in battle is a very unique and
refreshing take on the shonen hero trope
that is worth looking at in detail i've
really been looking forward to talking
about tanzido for a while now now even
though i criticized the character
writing overall in my video on why you
should watch demon slayer tanjiro is not
only an exception to this but also
easily one of the most interesting ones
in the show
[Music]
in a weird way he is your very
stereotypical shonen hero on the one
side and yet something entirely new and
different on the other and i find his
personality and philosophy extremely
fascinating hi my name is manu the only
demons i've ever slain are the
ridiculously large mosquitoes here in
japan like i absolutely hate killing any
living thing but for mosquitoes i can go
full berserk mode those are the true
demons where was i oh yeah i've been
absolutely obsessed with the beauty of
the kimitsu nuyba anime and so i just
had no other choice but analyzed its
main character and found some
surprisingly deep writing behind it what
do i mean by that well on the surface
tanjiro kamado fits the typical shonen
hero mold pretty pretty nicely he's a
young boy check who goes on an adventure
fighting bad guys check trying to get
stronger to reach his goal check and has
a hidden power he didn't know about all
along check now tanjido isn't from a
noble family but if you've ever dreamed
of being a lord or lady i might have
just the thing for you this video is
sponsored by established titles a really
great project with the goal to preserve
the beautiful woodlands and nature of
scotland by selling a tiny piece of land
to you because based on a historic
scottish custom where land owners are
referred to as a lord or a lady you can
then use this title for yourself even on
official documents that allow for it in
return in cooperation with the global
reforestation charities one tree planted
and trees for the future they commit to
planting a tree with every single order
and by the way it's also a great last
minute gift i think if you're still
looking for christmas presents as you
can see i got mine so i'm now officially
lord o'hara and you can even see where
your land is exactly located online they
actually have a big holiday sale going
on right now with up to 80 off and using
my code you can get an additional 10 off
link in the description below now
tanjido's desire his big goal is super
clearly defined and tells us a lot about
his character after his entire family is
murdered except for his sister who is
turned into a demon tanjiro doesn't seek
revenge but simply wants to save the
last remaining member of his family and
turn nasuko back into a human and this
perfectly sets up the most important
character trait overall his empathy and
i found this super super interesting
because tanjiro is kind or at least
empathetic even to the demons that he
encounters
he is the only one that is willing to
see them as people but at the same time
he still wants to turn nasiku back at
first i found that a little bit
paradoxical but when you actually think
about it it speaks of a certain maturity
he's able to see them as people who were
turned into demons but he still dislikes
the condition of being a demon for
obvious reasons i mean they eat people
and [ __ ] now usually for most heroes
beneath that superficial desire that
they have there is actually a
subconscious need that a character has
some sort of lie that they believe about
the world that needs to be challenged
now at the beginning of the series it
would be very easy to say that tanjido's
need is to lose his nativity you simply
can't emphasize with everyone especially
not if they're trying to kill you and so
to me at the start it seemed like his
kindness and hate for violence might be
a real hindrance in his fight against
the most evil and strongest beings in
this world however i got proven wrong
relatively quickly tanjiro proves to us
very early on that he can do both be
kind and caring and do what is necessary
at the same time he has a sort of eerie
but kind ruthlessness in him that result
in scenes like this
[Music]
the point that i found really
astonishing to be honest is that tanjiro
doesn't really have a need to change he
is an incredibly kind and caring person
with a strong will to fight and get
stronger to protect his sister and those
who need protection and he simply stays
that person and as a result tanjido has
close to no character development in the
story now just like me you probably know
a few people who proclaim that if a
character has no character development
it's a bad character
which is just not true a character is
bad if he is inconsistent or simply
straight out boring the reason tanjido
stands out as a shown in hiro with this
however is that most chonin protagonists
have a positive character arc they start
with a relatively obvious fall to the
character that they resolve at the end
of the story
foreign
[Applause]
and so since it's a positive character
arc they become better people as the
story goes on heck even a all-powerful
character like saitama and one punch man
needs to learn that true happiness
doesn't come from fighting strong and
strong opponents but from the
relationships that he has built a very
rare but really interesting variation on
this is a negative character arc where
the hero becomes this illusion with the
world and becomes a worse person like
for example gone in hanzo
on the other hand has a flat character
arc yep that is a real thing he already
has accepted the world as it is and has
chosen his path of how to approach it in
his case kindness
now flat arcs are very very rare in
shonen for a reason because the audience
expects the hero to grow and change as
they face harder and harder obstacles
and so as a result flat character arcs
can be really confusing or frustrating
to people a really great example of this
i think is ichigo from bleach he also
barely changes throughout the story and
only gets stronger physically the
problem is is that bleach is way too
long for such a hero and so it starts
becoming dull at some point which was
ultimately its downfall demon slayer on
the other hand is relatively short the
manga is already over and there might be
even less than 100 anime episodes at the
end of it which allows us to focus on
the world and people around tanjiro
without it getting all too boring that
being said flat arcs really depend on
your taste and if you prefer seeing
someone grow as a person then that's
fair i actually totally get that but
that doesn't automatically make it bad
writing in tonjiro's case his only flaw
is his physical weakness that he has to
continually fight and struggle against
he hates how useless he is and how he
cannot help the people he wants to help
now one big criticism i personally have
here is that i feel like the characters
around tanjuro could use way stronger
character arcs i genuinely think that
tanjido as a pillar of goodness would
have actually been some really great
writing if the people around him had
changed a lot more in his presence than
they do in the end shinobu and kanao are
the closest that we get but it could
have been a lot more impactful i
personally think the people who change
the most are the demons and that only
after being defeated which i find a bit
of a shame so what is tanzidor all about
then well as most heroes he is the foil
and exact opposite to the villain of the
story muzan in every aspect
everything from the motivations to the
ideals and values that there represents
while muzan only cares about himself and
sees everyone around him demons and
humans alike as tools to use for his
pleasure and desires tanjiro's central
defining trait is his altruism his
greatest priority will always be the
lives of the people around him and so
even though he's fighting against
literal demons he sees every last of
them as people and so while he doesn't
necessarily forgive and still condemns
them for their actions in the end he
acknowledges that all of them were human
beings at one point and tries his best
to respect their feelings even though he
has to take their lives in order to
protect his own or that of his friends
he tries to give them the kindness that
they were denied during their lifetime
giving them a bit of redemption and a
final chance to reflect on their lives
and so the challenge of his entire arc
is purely about finding strength and
power without throwing away his kindness
or his humanity instead of changing and
becoming a better or worse person
tanjiro is all about staying the great
man he already is he strongly embodies
the ideal of existentialism which is
basically the idea that his life derives
meaning and happiness from selflessly
giving to the people around him and
that's the point where he even tries to
give meaning to everyone that he meets
now even though the first season of
demon slayer was an absolute firework in
terms of production for me as i
explained in my previous video the mugen
train movie really took me by surprise
with its storyline especially for
tanjido the fact that we got to
physically enter everyone's deepest
desire and even more interestingly see
everyone's subconsciousness was an
incredibly creative choice in my opinion
i doubt that this was done on purpose
but the visual nature of the anime makes
up for a lot of the character writing in
my opinion and so literally visualizing
everyone's personality was a really
creative and awesome move touche i
wonder what my subconsciousness will
look like mostly coffee probably and you
gently hitting the subscribe button
anyways in tanjiro's dream instead of
returning back to his family left dead
after being massacred he finds them
alive and well instead well at first at
least
yes
[Laughter]
tanjido's desire is very simple to just
live a happy life with his family after
all he's just a simple charcoal burner
and a simple elder brother who became
the breadwinner at a young age after the
death of his father and so this dream
brings to light all of his trauma
regrets and guilt that he must have
carried with him at all times as he hugs
his siblings tightly apologizing over
and over again even though his dream
self doesn't know exactly why he was
apologizing and crying tanjito
understandably has a pretty severe case
of survivor's guilt as he was the only
one who got away unharmed especially as
the oldest brother
[Laughter]
it's really the first time since going
on his journey where he can pause and
reflect on that fact because he kept
himself distracted with his mission to
get stronger and at least save nizuko
but at the same time it once again shows
us that tanjiro is already mature and
prioritizes those around him instead of
allowing himself to be drawn in by the
thing that he wants the most he's able
to let go of the past in order to save
the people on board of the train hell he
even goes so far as to kill himself in
order to wake up which is pretty radical
if i'm being honest and yet despite all
the pain and regret inside him when we
get to enter tanjido's subconsciousness
it still is an endless oasis of love and
warmth with his core shining as bright
as the sun the thing that demons fear
the most even after all the traumatic
events he already had to live through he
still remains unconditionally kind to
the point where you could call him the
personification of kindness himself
the boy who entered this place was
reduced to tears and is healed from his
darkness exactly the thing i would have
liked to see for more characters around
him tanjiro is the son that frees people
and demons alike from the darkness of
their hearts and their eternal pain and
to me that's what makes him such a
unique character in the shonen genre